Let's talk about Geralt's
relationship with Ciri.
It's really the beating heart
of the show.
How has this bond changed Geralt
as a character?
I'm not too sure
if it's necessarily
changed Geralt
as a character.
Geralt has an instinctual desire
to protect,
as we see in Season 1
when he's telling Roach
about the first monster
he killed.
He's talking about protecting
someone against other people.
Throughout his life,
he has then tried
to fight this instinct,
and, ultimately,
the instinct
ends up winning
a number of times,
and that ends up getting him
into more trouble.
So this is actually more like
an unlocking for Geralt.
She's the key to allow him
to really be
who he has always wanted to be.
Freya, you had
an action-packed season.
New family,
new Witcher powers,
not so many runs
through the woods.
I don't know,
were you disappointed in that?
No, I was very relieved, yeah.
It was long-awaited
to get to finally actually,
yeah, pick up a sword.
Absolutely,
and you were wonderful.
Anya, Yennefer had a lot of
difficult choices this season,
especially after the loss
of her magic,
which I personally
was very devastated about.
-Yeah, me too.
-Yeah. How did you--
Imagine how Nilfgaard felt.
Oh yeah.
You should see the other guy.
They were literally devastated.
How did you feel
about the choices she made
with regard
to Geralt and Ciri?
Ooh.
How do I feel about it?
I kind of went through
the motions, you know,
with Yennefer,
kind of moment to moment.
In hindsight,
she made some rash decisions.
But I think, you know,
she didn't know, you know,
how to deal with the brutality
of the world without magic,
so, you know, her decision
to sacrifice Ciri
was the right one
in the moment.
And that's the thing
about this show,
is like there's no--
I don't know,
just it's up
to the audience
to kind of figure out
what's right or wrong.
And it's the beauty of kind of
exposing so much of a character
is you get to see why
they make a certain decision.
Joey, let's talk
all things Jaskier.
We see him with his
fancy new alias this season,
the Sandpiper.
If we include Dandelion
from the book,
so, what,
you have like three names now?
-Yeah.
-Well, what's that about?
Yeah, Lauren,
what's that about?
I think I'm gonna get
a new nickname per season.
Oh yeah? Okay.
The Knife.
You're not allowed
to pick them.
How is it exploring a new side
of your character this season?
He's way more emotionally
vulnerable this season.
I think in Season 1,
I was doing--
we were working so closely
together,
and he had this, like,
boyishness,
like a joy in him,
this kind of light
to a lot of the darkness
that you were just
talking about, Henry.
And he often felt like
it was his job
to brighten a room.
And we get to see that desire
kind of really tested
in a world that is
incredibly dangerous.
And for the first time
in his life,
he's getting the bejesus
kicked out of him
and he doesn't have his best
friend to come and help him.
And he's willing
to put his life on the line
to--to, you know, finally do
something good with his life,
-do something morally good.
-Yeah.
And that was... that was
the biggest treat for me.
I got to see this textured,
detailed character
that Lauren was so keen
to bring to the show.
Like what you see?
Be sure to check out
the full episode
of The Witcher: Unlocked,
the official Netflix Geeked
aftershow.